This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The only time you should really rob a bank is on a Friday afternoon. There's still need to be a way to steal something and get it out of the bank. The guiding principles you do not want to get caught. When I go into a bank, especially if I have to stand in line waiting to make a deposit, my mind Wonders and one of the. My mind wanders. And one of the first places it wanders to is how I would rob the place. I look at the exits and the entrances, the layout of the building. How could it be done?
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。你唯一真正应该抢银行的时候是在周五下午。仍然需要有一种方法来偷走东西并将其运出银行。核心指导原则是千万不要被抓住。当我走进银行时，特别是如果我必须排队等候存款时，我的思绪就会飘忽不定，其中一个……我的思绪飘忽不定。而我的思绪最先飘到的地方之一，就是我会如何抢劫这个地方。我观察出口和入口、建筑物的布局。这怎么可能做到？
Most of the time, buildings are our friends. But it's fun to recast the building as the enemy, the obstacle we have to overcome. Well, I guess it's a good thing we made our last Kickstarter goal. That's producer Katie Mingle. The puzzle of how to get the money out of the bank is one that our culture has been obsessed with for a long time. The first recorded bank robbery took place in the 1860s, and basically ever since we've been seduced by the idea of the heist and the people that do them. Today we'll meet three people who all tried in their own way to beat the bank, with designs
大多数时候，建筑物是我们的朋友。但把建筑重新设想为敌人，即我们必须克服的障碍，这很有趣。好吧，我想我们达成最后一个 Kickstarter 目标是一件好事。那是制作人凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）。如何将钱从银行里弄出来的谜题，是我们文化长期以来一直痴迷的事情。有记录的第一起银行抢劫案发生在 19世纪60年代，基本上从那以后，我们就一直被抢劫的创意以及那些实施抢劫的人所吸引。今天我们将认识三个人，他们都用各自的方式试图智取银行，其设计
that go from the spectacularly complicated to the deceptively simple. Oh, and one of them actually pulled it off. Several times. full-time. So I'm a Loneganer and I'm a designer and artist I'm based in London. My work relates to the idea that design can be a plot and I think what I'm fascinated by is the fact that it never has to happen so you have absolute freedom to fantasise about whatever you want. And with this in mind, Gainer set out to make her heist as big and complicated as possible, a sort of go big or go home style heist. And she was interested in the interplay between Hollywood movies about heists and real life Heists. This is really weird.
从极其复杂到看似简单。哦，其中一个人真的成功了。好几次。全职。所以我是洛内加纳（Lone Gainer），我是一名设计师和艺术家，我住在伦敦。我的工作与这样一种理念有关：设计可以是一个情节，我认为让我着迷的是这样一个事实：它永远不必发生，所以你有绝对的自由去幻想任何你想要的东西。带着这个想法，加纳着手让她的抢劫案尽可能宏大和复杂，这是一种“要么玩大的，要么回家”风格的抢劫案。她对好莱坞关于抢劫的电影与现实生活中的抢劫之间的相互作用很感兴趣。这真的很奇怪。
Feedback loops that happen in Hollywood. Hollywood being the intrinsic pull on everything that relates to the iconography of a Heist. So of course, her Heist had to take place in LA. There were years, mostly in the 70s, 80s and 90s, when LA was accurately dubbed the Bank robbery capital of the world. In particularly bad years, there were as many as 2,600 bank robberies in LA.
好莱坞发生的反馈循环。好莱坞是与抢劫标志性形象相关的一切事物的内在拉力。所以当然，她的抢劫案必须在洛杉矶发生。曾有多年，主要是在 70年代、80年代和90年代，洛杉矶被准确地称为世界银行抢劫之都。在特别糟糕的年份里，洛杉矶曾有多达 2600 起银行抢劫案。
That's roughly one robbery every 45 minutes of the working day. People have conjectured about why this is, gain or things. It may be the pull of Hollywood or the physical layout of LA. The way LA is constructed due to, though, obviously all the highways, it's actually very easy to get away. Oh, as long as you're not trying to get away during rush hour. To be fair to LA, their bank robbery stats are way less jaw-dropping now. According to the FBI, there were only 212 reported bank robberies in 2013.
这大约是工作日每 45 分钟发生一起抢劫案。加纳认为，人们一直在推测这是为什么。这可能是好莱坞的吸引力，或者是洛杉矶的物理布局。洛杉矶的建设方式，因为，显然所有的公路，实际上非常容易逃跑。哦，只要你不在交通高峰期试图逃跑。对洛杉矶来说公平的是，他们的银行抢劫数据现在已经没有那么让人惊叹了。根据联邦调查局（FBI）的数据，2013 年仅报告了 212 起银行抢劫案。
But let's get to Gainer's Heist. CHAPTER 1's called the distraction at one wheel show. Gainer ran a Kickstarter last year to fund her work. This is from the video. Picture this. Plane takes off from Los Angeles International Airport on Tuesday morning at precisely 9.46 a.m. It's assignment to deliver a full-scale replica of a 7.47 commercial jet to a film set.
但让我们来看看加纳的抢劫案。第一章被称为“单威尔希尔大厦的声东击西”。加纳去年发起了一个 Kickstarter 项目来资助她的工作。这是视频中的内容。想象一下。飞机于周二上午 9点46分准时从洛杉矶国际航空港起飞。它的任务是将一架 7.47 商业喷气式客机的全尺寸复制品运送到电影拍摄现场。
Whilst flying over downtown LA, the cables holding the replica snap, dropping the plane 10,000 feet, crashing into the government building, one Wilshire. One Wilshire is a 28-story building in downtown LA. Most of it is filled with computer servers and telecommunications equipment. The goal of it is to draw crowds of passes by and preoccupy police from what's really going on. And what's really going on is that while every emergency responder in LA is busy with the destruction at one wheelchair, five different banks in the surrounding area are being robbed.
当飞过洛杉矶市中心时，固定复制品的缆车断裂，导致飞机坠落 10,000 英尺，撞向政府大楼——威尔希尔一号（One Wilshire）。威尔希尔一号是洛杉矶市中心的一座 28 层大楼。大部分里面都装满了计算机服务器和电信设备。它的目的是吸引路人围观，并分散警察对真正发生的事情的注意力。而真正发生的事情是，当洛杉矶的每个应急响应人员都在忙于处理威尔希尔一号的破坏时，周边地区的五家不同银行正在被抢劫。
But Gainer's plan involves stealing the actual safes or vaults because that's where the big money is. It's become LA law now that they're only allowed to hold $2,000 at once, so if say for example they were ten tellers. Behind each cubicle you'd need ten people and the only amount that you'd ever get is a limit of two thousand dollars in each of those cubicles. Gainer's plan was to drill large concentric circles into the banks and pull out the vaults and then load them on a truck. We could carve circles that get smaller in size as you reach the vault and as you pull the goods
但加纳的计划涉及窃取实际的保险箱或金库，因为那是大钱所在的地方。现在洛杉矶法律规定他们一次只能持有 2,000 美元，所以如果比方说有十个出纳员。在每个隔间后面，你需要十个人，你所能得到的金额在每个隔间里都只有两千美元的限制。加纳的计划是在银行里钻出巨大的同心圆，拉出金库，然后把它们装上卡车。我们可以雕刻出随着你到达金库而尺寸变小的圆圈，当你把货物往后拉时
backwards it rips the building in part so that the building could collapse on its own weight after you've left, leaving no traces or trying to diminish the amount of evidence possible. Gainer did a ton of research trying to figure out the size of the vaults, the layout of the buildings. She was working with a group of students from the Art Center College of Design in LA. And we had them ask questions in the buildings, you know, kind of playfully, we're architecture students who want to find out how deep the building goes and so on. As of now, she knows the sizes of all the vaults, but one.
它会把建筑扯成两半，这样在你离开后建筑就会因自身的重量而倒塌，不留下任何痕迹，或者尽量减少可能的证据。加纳做了大量的研究，试图弄清楚金库的大小、建筑物的布局。她与洛杉矶艺术中心设计学院的一群学生合作。我们让他们在建筑里提问，你知道，有点开玩笑地说，我们是建筑系学生，想知道建筑有多深等等。截至目前，她知道所有金库的大小，除了一个。
The fifth one, we're still trying to work out. We've contacted a cleaner that has worked in one of the banks, but entering the vaults but one. The fifth one we're still trying to work out. We've contacted a cleaner that has worked in one of the banks, but entering the vault holds is very difficult. Not all of the research has been difficult though, like watching lots and lots of haste movies. The only thing the one you want to have in scene ironically is inside man and people keep telling me to watch it and I keep meaning to and it's one I'd like to savor because I'm told it's very good Heist to mastermind Russell Gowerts location New York City, New York
第五个，我们还在研究。我们联系了一位曾在其中一家银行工作过的清洁工，但是进入金库除了一个以外……第五个，我们还在研究。我们联系了一位曾在其中一家银行工作过的清洁工，但是进入金库非常困难。不过，并非所有的研究都很困难，比如观看大量大批的抢劫电影。具有讽刺意味的是，你在场景中唯一想看的是《局内人》（Inside Man），人们一直让我看，我也一直想看，这是我想细细品味的电影，因为有人告诉我这是一部非常棒的抢劫片。策划者罗素·格瓦茨（Russell Gewirtz），地点：纽约州纽约市
Hello, my name is Russell Gowerts. I'm the writer of the film inside man starring Jodie Foster Clibow and in Denzel Washington in the early 2000s sight man, starring Jody Foster, Clive Owen and Denzel Washington. In the early 2000s, GoWords was living in New York City. He wasn't a screenwriter, he had nothing to do with Hollywood. I hadn't gone to film school, I hadn't read a book on screenwriting or anything. He was just a guy working in real estate, that like me, and apparently a lot of other people, liked thinking about the best way to rob a bank. Part of my daily commute was that I'd walk for my apartment to my car a few blocks and
你好，我是罗素·格瓦茨。我是 2000 年代初由朱迪·福斯特、克里夫·欧文和丹泽尔·华盛顿主演的电影《局内人》的编剧。在 2000 年代初，格瓦茨住在纽约市。他不是编剧，他跟好莱坞没有任何关系。我没有上过电影学校，我没有读过一本关于编剧的书或任何东西。他只是一个在房地产行业工作的人，就像我一样，显然还有很多其他人，喜欢思考抢劫银行的最佳方式。我日常通勤的一部分是从我的公寓步行到我的车几个街区，然后
I'd walk past an empty bank. And every day when I was walking past this bank, that's what would pop into my head. So it was sort of like this. It was just this few minutes of my day every morning and every evening where I would end up working on this sort of fantasizing about this story in my mind. In fact, for about three years, Gowards constructed the perfect heist in his mind before he ever wrote down a word.
我会走过一家空置的银行。每天当我走过这家银行时，这就是会跳进我脑海的东西。所以有点像这样。每天早晨和每天晚上，我的一天中只有这短短的几分钟，我最终会在这类事情上工作，在我的脑海里幻想这个故事。事实上，在大约三年的时间里，格瓦茨在脑海中构建了完美的抢劫案，然后才写下一个字。
For most of that time, I don't think I ever really intended to write a movie. It was just, you know, just daydreaming. He knew he wanted his heist to take place in Manhattan, but it took him a while to figure out what kind of bank it would be. If you think about it, the story is dependent upon the architecture, if you will, or the structure. As I was writing it, I had to have a sense of, okay, is this a modern bank with glass? Can the cops see everything that's going on? Or is it old? And it just has smaller windows? And can they, you know, sometimes, you know, can they only see a little?
在大部分时间里，我想我从来没有真正打算写一部电影。这只是，你知道的，只是白日梦。他知道他希望他的抢劫案发生在曼哈顿，但他花了一段时间才弄清楚这将是哪种银行。如果你仔细想想，故事取决于建筑，如果你愿意的话，或者结构。当我写它的时候，我必须有一种感觉，好吧，这是一座带玻璃的现代银行吗？警察能看到正在发生的一切吗？还是旧的？它只有更小的窗户吗？他们能不能，你知道的，有时，你知道的，他们只能看到一点点？
Because that was going to determine how, you know, a lot of the action in the film. So the fun of it, the great part is that, as I'm writing it, I really get to build the bank, however I want it to be. The bank that Gorts ends up building is a classic old one. High ceilings, marble floors, elegant and uncomfortable in the way that big city banks used to be. And it has no windows in front, so the police have very little idea about what's going on inside with all the bank robbers and hostages.
因为这将决定电影中很多动作的方式。所以它的乐趣，最棒的部分是，当我写作时，我真的可以按照我想要的方式建造银行。格瓦茨最终建造的银行是一家经典的旧银行。高高的天花板，大理石地板，优雅却不舒服，就像大城市银行过去常有的那样。前面没有窗户，所以警察对里面抢劫犯和人质的情况知之甚少。
CBS2 News outside Manhattan Trust Bank, where we have just been told by investigators, the bank has been robbed. An okay spoiler alerts ahead, but the heist that he designs is really clever. A group of masked robbers enters the bank and takes everyone, all of the customers and all of the bank employees, hostage. Everybody get down on the floor! Down!
CBS2 新闻在曼哈顿信托银行外面报道，我们刚刚从调查人员那里获悉，该银行被抢劫了。好吧，前方剧透预警，但他设计的抢劫案真的很聪明。一群戴面具的抢劫犯进入银行，将每个人——所有的顾客和所有的银行员工——劫为人质。所有人趴到地上！趴下！
The robbers make all of the hostages take off their clothes and put on the same outfits that they, the robbers, are also wearing a kind of blue jumpsuit like a painter would wear in a mask. I need all of you to put on one of these suits on these masks. So you can't tell who's a hostage and who's a robber, even the hostages lose track of who's who. Toward the end of the movie, the hostages and robbers all come out with their hands up. But because they're dressed exactly the same,
劫匪让所有的人质脱下衣服，换上他们（劫匪）也穿着的同款服装——一种类似油漆工穿的蓝色连体工作服和面具。我需要你们所有人都穿上其中一套衣服，戴上这些口罩。所以你分不清谁是人质，谁是劫匪，甚至人质自己也分不清谁是谁。在电影接近尾声时，人质和劫匪都举着双手走了出来。但因为他们穿着一模一样，
the police have no idea who was a hostage and who was a robber. They question everyone, but they still can't figure it out. And eventually they have to let them all go. Kind of brilliant. But there was still one problem. It became clear to me that as clever as it was to hide them, you know, dress themselves up like the hostages, there still needed to be a way to steal something and get it out of the bank. You know, I couldn't, I couldn't sneak it
警察根本不知道谁是人质，谁是劫匪。他们盘问了所有人，但还是弄不明白。最终他们不得不把他们全放了。有点绝妙。但仍然有一个问题。我开始明白，尽管把他们藏起来——你知道的，把自己打扮成同人质一样的服装——是多么聪明，但仍然需要有一种方法来偷走东西并把它运出银行。你知道，我不能，我不能把它偷运
out in, you know, with the hostages. So, in the end, I decided one of them had to stay behind. And from there, it became well. If he stays behind, he has to be hiding. And if he's going to be hiding, it's got to be really clever. And it has to be something that is hinted at. Throughout the entire movie, while the robbers are in the bank, they're doing something in a back room, building something, digging something. It's unclear what's going on.
出去，你知道的，混在人质里。所以，最后，我决定他们中必须有一个人留下来。从那时起，就变成了：好吧。如果他留下来，他必须躲藏起来。如果他要躲藏，那必须非常巧妙。而且必须是有所暗示的东西。在整部电影中，当劫匪在银行里时，他们在后室里做着某事，建造着某事，挖掘着某事。目前还不清楚发生了什么。
You think that maybe they're digging a tunnel. What they're actually building is a room, a tiny cell with a false wall hidden behind some shelves in the basement of the bank. They use the building itself as an unwitting accomplice. One of the robbers, the one who actually has the stolen goods, has to stay behind until all the police are gone, until they're done gathering evidence at the bank. He has to stay in this little room for an entire week.
你可能会认为他们在挖一条隧道。他们实际建造的其实是一个房间，一个隐藏在银行地下室一些货架后面的假墙后面的微型牢房。他们把建筑物本身当作了一个不知情的同谋。其中一个劫匪，也就是真正拿着赃物的那个人，必须留下来，直到所有警察都离开，直到他们在银行收集完证据。他必须在这个小房间里呆整整一个星期。
You know, it's funny, it's hard for me to know exactly how much of my intention actually came through, but when they're hacking through the concrete floor, they're building a toilet. Because if you're hiding in a tiny cell for a week, well, you're going to have to go somewhere. And that's the thing about this heist. It feels pretty believable.
你知道，这很有趣，我很难确切知道我的意图有多少真正传达出来了，但当他们用凿子凿开混凝土地面时，他们在建一个厕所。因为如果你要在一个微型牢房里躲藏一个星期，好吧，你总得去某个地方。这就是这场抢劫案的奇妙之处。它感觉相当可信。
There are no black boxes in this movie. And if you're watching a movie and a bunch of crooks get to the safe, and somebody just pulls out a piece of equipment from a backpack and sticks it on the lock and the lock opens, that's called a blackba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba-bibba reality of how most bank robberies take place. According to the FBI's own statistics, most bank robberies are done by just a single person who presents a note to the teller and walks out without a lot of fanfare. Which is a fundamental principle of design. If you want something to work and work well, keep it simple.
这部电影里没有黑色方块。如果你在看一部电影，一群骗子找到了保险箱，而有人只是从背包里拿出一件设备把它粘在锁上，锁就打开了，这被称为黑盒……（卡壳重复）……这与大多数银行抢劫案发生的现实相去甚远。根据联邦调查局自己的统计数据，大多数银行抢劫案都是由单个人完成的，他们向出纳员递上一张便条，不费吹灰之力就走了出去。这是设计的一个基本原则。如果你想让某事发挥作用并且运作良好，那就保持简单。
Heist 3. Mastermind. Tom Justice. Locations. California. Illinois. And Wisconsin. So all of the other people I'm talking to for this show, designed, bank robberies, or bank heists as kind of a creative exercise, but that's not the case with you. Oh, that's correct. I have unfortunately been convicted of 26 bank robberies in three different states. In my case, they called me the choir boy robber. The FBI gave Tom this name because during the robberies, he would stand with his hands folded on the counter and his head bowed. When I can't see someone's hands, that makes me very nervous.
抢劫案 3。策划者。汤姆·杰斯蒂斯（Tom Justice）。地点。加利福尼亚州。伊利诺伊州。和威斯康星州。所以我为这个节目采访的所有其他人，设计银行抢劫案，或者将银行抢劫案作为一种创意练习，但你并非如此。哦，那是对的。不幸的是，我因在三个不同的州犯下 26 起银行抢劫案而被定罪。在我的情况下，他们称我为“唱诗班男孩劫匪”。FBI 给汤姆起了这个名字，因为在抢劫过程中，他会双手交叠放在柜台上，微微鞠躬。当我看不到某人的手时，这会让我非常紧张。
So in order to sort of make myself calm and, you know, a bank teller calm, I would just put your hands folded nicely, just put them right there, put everybody at ease. Tom always worked alone and he always used a note. The note always read, this is a bank robbery, put all of your money in the bag, thank you. And you have to be prepared for the teller to think the note is a joke. It's interesting, it breaks your stride a little bit because you're sort of in this zone. And then the teller, she looks at me like, are you serious? Yes, serious.
因此，为了让我自己平静下来，你知道的，让银行出纳员平静下来，我就会把双手整齐地折叠好，把它们放在那里，让所有人都放松下来。汤姆总是独自作案，而且他总是使用字条。字条上总是写着：“这是一场银行抢劫案，把所有的钱放进袋子里，谢谢。”你必须做好出纳员认为字条是个玩笑的准备。这很有趣，它有点打乱你的节奏，因为你有点处于这个状态中。然后出纳员，她看着我，仿佛在问：你是认真的吗？是的，认真的。
Because if you've never experienced this before, and who has, you think it's a joke. And like a loner-gainer, the artist that we heard from earlier, Tom did his research, especially at the beginning. Probably took three, four months of research and a lot of observation. The guiding principles you do not want to get caught. And as such, you want to envision all sorts of different scenarios.
因为如果你从来没有经历过这种事，而谁又经历过呢，你会以为这是个玩笑。就像我们之前听到的艺术家罗内·加纳一样，汤姆做了他的研究，特别是在开始的时候。可能花了三、四个月的研究和大量的观察。核心指导原则是千万不要被抓住。因此，你想要设想各种不同的情景。
Someone might engage you in the bank, a bank employee, a bank customer, what will you do? If you reach an altercation, what is your escape route? Because it might be different from your standard route. Everything has to be highly thought out. Tom's getaway vehicle. What's his bicycle? So the first thing you do was figure out where he was going to leave the bike parked while he was inside robbing the bank from there. I actually physically walked it through in terms of the steps.
可能会有人在银行里与你搭讪，一个银行员工，一个银行客户，你会怎么做？如果你遇到争执，你的逃跑路线是什么？因为它可能与你的常规路线不同。一切都必须经过深思熟虑。汤姆的逃跑交通工具。是什么？他的自行车。所以你要做的第一件事是弄清楚当他在里面抢劫银行时，他要把自行车停在哪里，从那里开始。我实际上亲自一步步走了一遍。
I would actually count the steps. I would count the moves. I would actually count the steps. I would count the moves. I would practice literally hundreds of times. I had a small notebook in which I wrote down every single detail. Would you leave footprints, police patterns, possibilities, high pedestrian traffic areas?
我实际上会数步数。我会计算行动。我实际上会数步数。我会计算行动。我会字面意义上练习几百次。我有一个小笔记本，里面记下了每一个细节。你会留下脚印、警察的巡逻规律、可能性、高人流量区域吗？
Tom spent a lot of time observing police patterns and completely unintuitively. He came to believe. Banks closest to cop stations make for the softest targets. Tom thinks this is because when cops go out on duty they tend to drive out a ways from the station, which means it takes them longer to get to the scene if they're called back for a robbery. And he tended to rob banks in middle to upper-class neighborhoods so that it would look like it would support somebody riding away on a bicycle. If you were in it to be in a really tough area, a really working class area, that would stand out. Now I did not lock up my bike. Honestly, I was only away from that site two to three minutes.
汤姆花了很多时间观察警察的巡逻规律，而且完全不合常理。他逐渐相信。离警察局最近的银行往往是最容易下手的目标。汤姆认为这是因为警察出警时往往会开出局里一段距离，这意味着如果他们因抢劫而被召回，他们需要更长的时间才能赶到现场。而且他倾向于在中产阶级到上流阶层社区抢劫银行，这样看起来才像是一个骑自行车逃跑的人。如果你在一个真正艰难的地区，一个真正的工人阶级地区，那会很显眼。现在我没有锁上我的自行车。老实说，我离开那个地方只有两到三分钟。
Over the course of four years, Tom stole close to $130,000. So that's about $5,000 per robbery. He never used a gun, and no one was ever physically hurt. Toward the end of his bank robbing career, Tom got careless and stopped putting as much time into the planning. Did all of the standard steps of what is the escape route and what is the alternate escape route
在四年的时间里，汤姆窃取了近 13 万美元。所以每次抢劫大约 5,000 美元。他从未用过枪，也从未有人受到身体上的伤害。在银行抢劫生涯的末期，汤姆变得粗心大意，不再投入那么多时间进行规划。做了所有标准步骤，什么是逃生路线以及什么是备用逃生路线
but I did not really pay attention to like the police you know will hang out and watch police patterns. I just got a cocky. Tom Justice was eventually caught and spent nine years in prison. Design matters. and spent nine years in prison. Design matters. Hey, you want to know what else matters? What? Heat. We want to hurt no one.
但我并没有真正关注比如警察，你知道的，会闲逛并观察警察的巡逻规律。我只是变得自负了。汤姆·杰斯蒂斯最终被捕，并在监狱里度过了九年。设计很重要。并在监狱里度过了九年。设计很重要。嘿，你想知道还有什么重要吗？什么？《盗火线》（Heat）。我们不想伤害任何人。
We're here for the bank's money, not your money. Your money is insured by the federal government. You're not going to lose a dime. The 1995 movie, Heat, from director Michael Mann, set in LA, of course, it influenced all three of our heist masterminds. Heat to me is, you know, one of the most perfect films I've ever seen. I kind of have seen lots over the years. My favorite being heat, Michael Mann's heat. In prison, heat is the number one movie amongst convicts. Whenever say we're all hanging out on a Saturday and heat comes on TNT and it's on at an odd time.
我们来这里是为了银行的钱，不是你的钱。你的钱由联邦政府担保。你不会损失一毛钱。1995 年由迈克尔·曼（Michael Mann）导演的电影《盗火线》，背景当然是洛杉矶，它影响了我们所有的三位抢劫策划者。在我看来，《盗火线》是，你知道的，我看过的最完美的电影之一。这些年来我看了很多。我最喜欢的是《盗火线》，迈克尔·曼的《盗火线》。在监狱里，《盗火线》是罪犯中最受欢迎的电影。每当比如说我们在一个星期六闲逛，TNT 电视台播放《盗火线》，而且播放时间很奇怪。
Whatever it is you're doing, you sort of set down. I'm going to watch at least an hour of this. Craft projects, shankings, you put it all aside for heat. And the Heist designers in our story aren't the only ones influenced by heat. There was a real heist in LA in 1997 dubbed the North Hollywood shootout. You can actually watch and listen to parts of it online. It's about three questions out there.
无论你在做什么，你都会放下手头的事。我要看至少一个小时。工艺品、自制武器，你把这一切都放在一边，只为《盗火线》。我们故事中的抢劫设计者并不是唯一受《盗火线》影响的人。1997 年在洛杉矶发生了一场真实的抢劫案，被称为北好莱坞枪击案。你实际上可以在网上观看和聆听其中的一部分。外面有三个问题。
They're going to walk in long, really, and they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they're going to say, they It's a robbery on a bank of America gone awry and it all unfolds in a way that is suspiciously similar to the plot of heat. This is really weird. Feedback loops that happen in Hollywood.
他们要走很长一段路，真的，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，他们会说，这是一起美国银行的抢劫案，结果却出了差错，这一切展开的方式与《盗火线》的剧情惊人地相似。这真的很奇怪。好莱坞发生的反馈循环。
It seems when it comes to heists, life often imitates art. And all of these plans are only good as art, I cannot stress this enough people, crime doesn't pay. But if you must embark on a life of crime, remember this. Don't let yourself get attached to anything you're not willing to walk out on at 30 seconds flat if you feel the heat around the corner. 99% Invisible was producedced This Week by Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced are the
看来在抢劫这件事上，生活往往在模仿艺术。所有这些计划作为艺术只能算是不错，我怎么强调这一点都不为过，朋友们，犯罪是不会有好下场的。但如果你必须踏上犯罪生涯，请记住这一点。不要让自己依恋任何在你感觉到危险临近时，不愿意在短短 30 秒内抛弃的东西。《99% Invisible》本周由凯蒂·明格与萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 的一个项目，制作于
offices of Arc Sign, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California, around the corner from the Chase Bank, which has a wall of inch thick loose sight between you and the tellers. So you ain't getting in there. Don't even think about it. You can follow along with this show and all the people who make this show on Facebook, and Twitter, and Tumblr, but I think your mission this week is to describe your perfect heist in great detail in the comments at 99p i dot org.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的 Arc Sign 办公室，转角处就是大通银行（Chase Bank），银行里你和出纳员之间有一堵一英寸厚的有机玻璃墙。所以你进不去。甚至不要去想它。你可以在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Tumblr 上关注这个节目以及所有制作这个节目的人，但我认为你本周的任务是在 99pi.org 的评论区详细描述你的完美抢劫案。
Radio to Pew from PRX. PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX 的广播电台。PRX。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。